Egypt has a population of Coptic
Christians and two bombs exploded at
Coptic churches in Alexandria and Ponte
Egypt the Alexandria explosion was a
suicide bombing according to the
interior ministry and the police
actually stopped a terrorist with an
explosive belt from breaking into the
church and along with civilians and a
policeman and a policewoman a number of
those staff and law enforcement
individuals were killed in tanta 30
people and were killed and at least 70
were injured in Alexandria 16 were
killed and 35 were injured now Isis
later claimed the attacks through its
amaq news agency after having warned
that it was going to step up attacks on
Egypt's Christians and as usual it's
really hard to independently verify that
Isis was involved at all we have only
what they say through their own news
agency what would the motives be for
Isis to do this well Isis wants to kill
non-muslims that's pretty clear at this
point and for people who don't know
Coptic Christians make up about ten
percent of Egypt's population of 85
million and of course they've had issues
but they've actually coexisted with
Egypt's majority Muslim population for a
very long time hundreds of years but
they have faced more and more
persecution discrimination since the
Mubarak regime fell in 2011 we've seen
Coptic churches and homes set on fire
members of the Coptic minority
physically attacked property looted
Amnesty International has been reporting
about a lot of this since last March and
this is part of why regime change for
secular dictators in the Middle East
North Africa region often just doesn't
work Pat we see power vacuums with a
Sunni majority turn into effectively
open season on religious minorities
especially Christians and you know we
often get criticized Pat we never report
when Christians are attacked that is
such BS we
have been reporting on it for a long
time we don't do the thing that we are
often accused of strategically ignoring
stories this is a disaster we have been
reporting on it will continue reporting
on it and this is part of a much bigger
military buildup that we are seeing
involving the Korean Peninsula as well
as what's going on in Syria this is a
bigger picture issue right now and
unfortunately when it comes to the
corporate media it's kind of a back page
story at this point because of
everything else is going on with my area
with Stockholm but 36 people died and
you know regardless of where it happens
in the world I know sometimes we get
desensitized because you know this
happened in Africa this happen in the
Middle East doesn't seem too far out of
place but the diplomatic response the
humanitarian response that should all be
the same and that should be reflected
immediate and although these are
unrelated events right the serious
strikes the build up around the Korean
Peninsula with North Korea which we'll
talk about later in the show this is all
fomenting the drums of war the feelings
of uncertainty and lack of safety and
and sort of priming people to be more
open to military action although why
would these attacks in Egypt make us
more open to military action in Syria
well it doesn't follow logically but we
know that when these types of stories
are in the muse more it makes people
more open to military action and this is
why you know the YouTube ad boycott is
especially untimely because it is it is
hamstringing corporate independent media
and moving the money towards corporate
media at a time when corporate media is
basically beating the drums of hey let's
do this let's do that with our military
and even before the advocaat anytime we
covered foreign policy and stories like
this these videos will get D monetized
anyway so this was going on for months
before the Advocate no doubt about it
and a lot of discussion about Syria
Egypt Stockholm which we will also talk
about a big foreign policy day oh yeah
today actually the biggest we've ever
had actually a lot of these discussions
happening on our reddit discussion forum
and I encourage you to go to david
pakman.com slash reddit sign up and
participate in the conversation